la ciudad de severodonezk es controlada
en gran parte por el ejército ruso
la situación actual no ha cambiado el
70% sigue bajo control ruso bajo el
control del ejército ruso
alrededor del 10 o 15% es una especie de
zona gris y el resto del territorio está
en manos de nuestros defensores
y es una de las ciudades clave en la
región oriental de ucrania y si cayera
dejaría lysychansk justo al otro lado
del río como la última zona importante
de resistencia en el este en las afueras
de la ciudad los residentes están
confinados en refugios antibombas como
estos
no hay electricidad agua o gas en la
ciudad los chicos se levantan a las 5 y
30 de la mañana traen agua corta leña y
cocinan en una hoguera y nos dan agua
caliente intentan cocinar algunas
comidas calientes para nosotros
y
muchos de los que escaparon de la ciudad
se han dirigido al oeste accra motors
pero ni siquiera y se sienten a salvo ya
que muchos temen nuevos avances rusos
es más seguro aquí que en otras partes
de donges miembros pero será mejor que
se vayan los rusos están ganando terreno
no los detienen por eso hay que seguir
huyendo miles de residentes que no han
podido huir de la ciudad permanecen
atrapados y las autoridades dicen que
las evacuaciones se han detenido por los
combates